I actually got attached at the same time
as I got attached to this movie it crazy
rich Asians it was a time when I was
looking for a story that meant more
something more personal to me and I had
seen the show and to me the immigrant
story has been under attack this idea of
what America is is something that that I
grew up with of that you view America's
the greatest place in the world if you
work hard and love what you do you can
do anything it's when my parents came
from China and didn't know a word of
English started a Chinese restaurant
raised five kids fifty years later next
year it's still there my dad's still in
the kitchen so anything was possible and
of course the youngest son myself got
into the most American business in the
world Hollywood that is only proof of
how Great America can be and and what I
love about in the heights is its Lin's
story ultimately living in Washington
Heights in New York City and and having
that same community of immigrants that
where their dreams are are beyond what
you could ever imagine and and finding
home so that movie and that's that the
story always was compelling to me at the
time Hamilton wasn't out yet so he
wasn't the hottest thing in the world
although the show had won Best Musical
in the Tony Awards so I attached myself
to it and we didn't know if it was ever
gonna get picked out or how it was how
they would if Harvey would ever make
this movie or not so we did our thing
and it's a hard transition actually from
the show to a movie so we we kept
breaking it and breaking and breaking it
and I think we got a really great
combination so it's really nice to be
free and at Warner Brothers the same
studio who's who's doing creative
occasions completely when you when you
think about all the other musicals that
have been converted or made into a movie
is there one that you would compare like
are you looking is there one out there
that looks like or feels like something
that you're trying to do with this or is
it you know how would you describe the
tone what you're trying to do with it I
sometimes think about do the right thing
which is not a musical but has a really
cool vibe to it speak some truths but is
but it's sort of in this visual world
that I loved and and and and pop to it I
I think of I think of Annie Hall the
playfulness of Annie Hall
where it's it's not the typical love
story but at the same time it's enough
freedom to be able to do scenes that are
related with a drawing on the on the
screen or or breaking the fourth wall so
this has a little bit of that it's a
story that's being told to us through
snobby and and because it's a musical
you have some of those freedoms to do so
when we think about New York I think
about usually it's New York
that is the centerpiece to your to your
visuals it's like how could you up New
York but in this one it's what do New
Yorkers dream about what do the people
in in Washington Heights dream about and
and and how do you bring the wonder in
the everyday things of the city
sure are you I know it's early but you
ever released it so do you know when
you're filming
we're shooting next summer in Washington
Heights I was gonna ask you that's the
next part yeah I would imagine that this
is one of these things we're filming on
location is everything everything so to
bring the audience not just bring
Washington Heights to them and where the
theater does but to actually bring them
into Washington Heights where Lin still
lives is pretty epic and we're gonna be
taking over those streets so that'll be
fun it'll be hot - yeah I was gonna say
it's not gonna be cold
no so what what a cameo / what's Lin
doing it I can't talk about that right
now we're figuring that out you know
he's a very busy man but I'm assuming he
wants to be a part of it in some way for
sure and he's gonna be definitely behind
the scenes and and hopefully in front of
the scenes but we were as we get inch
closer and and his schedule starts to be
more planned out then we'll have a
better scene but he's been very involved
and what a great collaborative
he is every bit of the genius that you
see on TV and you see and those great
talk shows where he's where he's riffing
and in his work he is full-on through in
the same way as the rock a good human
being and an amazing creator um yeah I
hear that from everybody about him in
fact well obviously both of them yeah
but uh who wrote the most recent draft
chiara who wrote the original book and
they were she did the original one when
they were in college together so that's
crazy and she's his neighbor so every
time we need a change it's not like okay
we got to tell Lynn we'll
to prove and did it as she's like hold
on one second hey we're changing we're
taking that song out is that okay yeah
that's fine and then we change that
that's amazing
I know where the more careful than that
but it's basically that something that
this is completely random but I've also
the theater-going experience something
that I love is like IMAX and that making
it on the biggest possible screen that
you can get does that ever come up in
the conversation of like shooting a
musical in IMAX to take it to like that
next level for sure this is my first
musical so all those discussions are
being had as we speak for sure what the
format is how do we how would you take
it to the next level how do what's the
reason for making this musical right now
how do we present it as an event to
everyone who's coming to see it because
it is an event so all the Teno cast are
almost all the teen oh there's there's
one part that's not but and and we have
this amazing musical award-winning
musical and you have Lynn to to help
tell the story so it's it's a pretty
epic event my last question about that
film casting process yeah I would
imagine that this is something that
people need to do a lot of rehearsal a
lot of practice lay down the tracks
before you get on set yeah all of that
yeah so where are you in the casting
process we're in the beginning we've
gone through a process before and we
narrowed down some things but we're
starting from scratch and and seeing
everybody again and seeing cuz you know
when dates change then availability
changes but we've seen some amazing
talent all around the world we'll
continue to search I think that what I
learned from crazy rich Asians is that
it takes more time and more money when
you are searching for underrepresented
characters in the cinema space so I want
to do my due diligence and to turn over
every rock first and foremost and then
make the best decision for the
characters you don't have to have Tom
Cruise as your lead you don't have to
have some giant star as really you just
have to find the best storytellers
because the story is much bigger than
anything that we could bring otherwise
so
you